un bras de mer large d'un peu plus de 10
kilomètres entre la côte turque et l'île
grecque de lesbos passage obligé pour
presque tous les migrants point de
départ d'un long périple
il suffit d'une balade en mer à bord
d'une barque de pêcheurs pour le
confirmer
l'un d'eux deux bateaux facilement 50
personnes
le va et vient des bateaux pneumatiques
est ici constants en quelques heures
nous comptons plus d'une douzaine de
départs impossible cependant de
s'approcher
notre capitaine a peur les grassi quand
ils sont armés
alors nous tenterons notre chance de
l'autre côté sur la terre ferme
une crique isolée loin de là où
plusieurs années sur le sol nous montre
que nous avons trouvé le bon endroit
et puis une surprise tous deux coups
sortie décevoir une longue colonne demi
leur désaccord sans doute aussi étonné
que nous de cette rencontre au milieu de
nulle part
celui ci nous dit qu'il n'a pas dix
lettres sauvetage mais que sa femme en a
un
son bébé non plus n'a pas de bruit nous
leur souhaitons bonne chance
ils sont environ 200 presque tous
afghans
parmi eux un jeune homme de 18 ans
mohammed reza rezaï
à peine sorti de l'école secondaire je
suis je un niang g début j'ai envie d'un
avenir meilleur
il est ici avec huit de ses amis fans
nous d'après j'ai vu dans la presse tous
les migrants qui vont en europe en
autriche en allemagne
je me suis dit pourquoi pas - mohamed
reza a payé 2000 $ pour cette traversée
une fortune pour son père qui ne gagne
que 20 dollars par jean cau assistante
chef
bien sûr ce dont je retiens quiz prend
de gros risques mais je pense que c'est
nécessaire
à quelque part une famille attend
patiemment elle aussi l'embarquement el
miri azimi un fermier de la région
d'heracles est malade il veut aller en
allemagne se faire soigner sa femme
failli me résouds à elle veut surtout
essayer de retrouver son fils par six
pour l'europe et aussi mais dont elle
n'a qu'une nouvelle depuis deux mois si
elle a accepté l'idée de cette folle
traversée c'est pour ces enfants sages à
riec harrach et la petite mes enfants ne
sont pas en sécurité quand ils vont à
l'école il y à des bombes du gaz
beaucoup de difficultés nous retrouvons
mohammed reza sur la plage une fois la
mer pour la première fois de sa vie des
cours avec étonnement que l'eau est
salée
il ya un état de santé ici
ah si je vois de l'espoir entre les deux
il ya la mer et je dois la traversée sur
la berge
il remarque et inspectent la carcasse
échoué d'un bateau pneumatique qui a
coulé sa confiance est ébranlée oui ça
date bottes quand je vois ce bateau
coule et ça me fait vraiment pas et la
foule qui nous lui prêtons un téléphone
pour qu'il appelle ses parents
wazemmes crédit volontairement sa
famille lui apparaît tout à coup
cruellement loin à 10 mm et la soeur de
6 ans je laime vraiment ça fait une
semaine que je vous jure
parmi les migrants qui attendent pour
s'embarquer beaucoup d'enfants beaucoup
de bébés les bouées de piscine qui leur
servent les jeux les sauvetages fort
tous un avertissement ne pas utiliser
sur un bateau d'ailleurs ils sont très
jeunes
5 6 ans db c'est trop dangereux pour
tous et d'un grèce prenait le soleil va
bientôt se coucher ici la tension est
remontée d'un cran c'est palpable ici
les migrants vient de se faire dire de
se préparer parce que le départ est
imminent pour la plupart de ces gens
c'est la première fois qu'ils vont
prendre le bateau
mohamed reza cet effet jury par les
passeurs que seuls 35 passagers prendre
place à bord de son bateau
il vient d'apprendre qu'ils seront en
fait près de cinq ans de deux fois et
demie la capacité maximale f comme si tu
veux on va traverser
non on voit tout ce que la nuit tombait
profitant de l'obscurité les pacers 114
ans les passagers sont intimidés battue
menacé pour mieux leur faire accepter
les terribles conditions de la traversée
mohamed reza sec de plus en plus des
captages mannix le capitaine n'a même
pas l'expérience
il n'a jamais varié bateau driving beau
nous lui remettons une caméra pour
qu'elle filme sa traversée ces images en
raconte la sunni surchargé le bateau
prend rapidement l'eau le moteur est
noyé le pneumatique dérive au milieu de
la mer egée ses passagers sur maintenant
d'ofra j'ai hâte hâte à ce moment là je
n'avais plus d'espoir on se dit qu'on
allait tous mourir soient noyées soit à
cause du manque d'eau de nourriture
on était certain
un drapeau blanc et tisser pour attirer
l'attention d'un navire en vain après
avoir dérivé pendant cinq heures les
passagers se met à ramer avec les mains
après huit heures de traversée les
naufragés sont enfin secourus
c'est un sentiment incroyable
une heure plus tôt vous êtes certain
mourir et puis on a tout change de ce
qu'on les aime
aujourd'hui en revoyant ses images avec
ses amis vont ramer dressa se considère
comme un miraculé heureux d'être en vie
mais en colère contre les passeurs qui
met ainsi en péril la vie des migrants
pour gagner plus d'argent
les trafiquants sont les pires personne
au monde ne respecte pas la vie humaine
ne sont pas humains le jour où mohamed
reza traverser treize personnes sont
mortes noyées dans ses enfants
après cette épreuve le groupe d'amis
essaie maintenant de se reposer et de
reprendre des forces
touche le savent ils ne sont encore
qu'au début d'un long périple et s'ils
pensent aujourd'hui poursuivre son
chemin ne serait ce que pour donner un
sens à tous les risques qu'il a pris
mohamed reza thiêt a lancé un appel à
tous ceux qui pensent à s'exiler comme
lui dans les mêmes conditions nos manies
nova des personnes
je répète personne ne devrait faire ce
voyage c'est trop dangereux
au bord de la mort savez ça ne vous
témoignage très éclairant ces images
elles ont été tournées en fin de semaine
ce soir mohammed reza est toujours dans
l'île de lesbos
il espère embarquer sur la traversée
mercredi pour continuer sa route en
europe